today's video is brought to you by
fabulous star building better habits
with fabulous in its science-backed data
routines more in them in a bit
the mid-1980s were a pretty good time
for los angeles the city was coming off
hosting the 1984 summer olympic games
still considered the most profitable
olympics in modern times it had also
just overtaken the city of chicago as
the second most populous city in the
country he was also gearing up for a
visit from the pope and the la lakers
were the most popular thing in sports
but not always well because los angeles
had a bogeyman one who was very real and
much scarier than all of his fictional
counterparts like freddy krueger he
attacked when people were at their most
vulnerable at night when they were in
bed young bold middle-aged men women
nobody was safe from richard ramirez the
sick depraved devil-worshiping killer
who became known as the night stalker
[Music]
for years the violent fantasies of our
killer remained just that fantasies
however it was inevitable that one day
he would try to live out his depraved
dreams and he finally did it on june 28
1984. his target was a 79 year old woman
named jenny vince who lived in a los
angeles neighborhood called glass or
park it is unclear what made ramirez
choose her but it is likely that she was
a victim of opportunity she had left a
window open during the night because it
was hot and the killer probably saw our
home that was easy to break into he
simply removed a screen and climbed
inside once he was in ramirez unleashed
a furious and merciless attack on this
helpless victim jenny vincao was beaten
raped stabbed and had her throat slashed
so violently that she had been nearly
decapitated afterwards the killer took
his time and ransacked the place looking
for valuables to sustain his drug
addiction this pattern would become the
modus operandi for the man who would go
on to drive the city of los angeles into
a state of abject terror but that was
still about a year away at this point
for whatever reason ramirez cooled off
after the vinca murder waiting almost
nine months before striking again but
when he did his killing spree began in
earnest and los angeles was now facing
the wrath of the night stalker on march
the 17th 1985 22 year old maria
hernandez pulled into the garage of a
home in rosemead california she got out
of her car when she was approached by a
strange man dressed in all black and
wearing a baseball cap pulled down low
over his head who then pointed a gun at
her face maria begged for mercy but her
pleas fell on deaf ears as man pulled
the trigger a loud bang shook the garage
and maria fell to the floor as the
shooter kicked her body out of the way
to enter the house his complete
disregard for her ended up being her
salvation because if he would have
looked closer he would have seen that
maria hernandez was still alive
instinctually she raised her hands when
ramirez pointed his gun at her head and
in a one-in-a-million shot the bullet
ricocheted off the car keys that maria
was holding in her hand and simply
grazed her her 34 year old roommate dale
okazaki did not share her fortune dale
had heard the gunshot and was hiding
behind the kitchen counter when ramirez
walked up to her and shot her killing
her instantly afterwards ramirez walked
out the house and ran into maria
hernandez trying to stumble away he
could have easily gunned her down if he
wanted but instead he decided to put his
weapon back in his belt and simply walk
away we don't know what prompted this
action but it's certainly not because
his bloodlust had been satiated just an
hour later the criminal struck again
when he pulled thirty-year-old sai lian
yu out of her car shot her twice and
then ran away you were still alive when
the police found her but she died before
reaching the hospital it did not take
long for the police to link these crimes
together mainly because all the
shootings were done with a 22-caliber
handgun and witnesses at both scenes
provided descriptions of the same man he
was tall thin either white or a
light-skinned latino with dark curly
hair and rotting teeth the violent and
seemingly random nature of the attacks
alerted the public and the police as the
media referred to the criminal as the
valley intruder
it only took 10 days before the night
stalker struck again on march the 27th
the killer broke into the home of
vincent and maxine zazara located in
whittier los angeles county he shot both
husband and wife in the head killing
them instantly but he then proceeded to
indulge his sadistic side on mrs azara
she was found naked and mutilated with
numerous stab wounds all over her body
and her eyes had been gouged out this
would become a recurring theme with the
night stalker as the criminal refined
his killing method to line up with his
twisted fantasies the men were
dispatched quickly as they were mere
obstacles so that he could focus his
attention on the women after the death
of the zazarus the nightstalker put on
the brakes for a bit waiting almost two
months before another deadly attack but
just because the night stalker was not
active did not mean that neither was
richard ramirez unlike many other serial
killers ramirez preoccupied his time
with a lot of other crimes including
burglary theft kidnapping rape and
assault most disturbing were a series of
child abductions that started in
february 1985 around the san gabriel
valley all the children had been taken
to abandoned buildings or construction
sites where they were sexually assaulted
and then abandoned but several of them
were able to provide descriptions of
their attacker that would later prove
instrumental in convicting him it was
these descriptions that first caused one
of the lead investigators in the case
detective gil guerrillo to suspect that
the same man might be responsible for
all of these crimes the one detail that
stood out to him was the criminal's bad
teeth and foul breath one characteristic
that all of his victims noticed not many
other investigators bought the idea at
first the same guy kidnapping children
while also breaking into people's homes
and killing them while they slept
sometimes using a gun and sometimes
using a knife sometimes just shooting
them once while other times mutilating
the bodies not to mention that these
crimes targeted children young women
middle-aged couples in the elderly well
anything was possible of course but this
was considered simply too unlikely if
carrillo wanted anyone to believe his
hypothesis he would need a bit more
evidence and bad breath fortunately for
him he soon got it in the form of a shoe
print the knight stalker had left a very
distinct shoe print at the zazara crime
scene it came from a avia sneaker size
11 and a half most likely black based on
witness descriptions police checked with
the manufacturer and discovered that
just six pairs of sneakers matching that
criteria had been shipped in the entire
united states with a single pair being
sold in los angeles because the model
had just come out earlier that year as
one of the detectives put it it was
almost like a signed signature then
during one of the child abductions the
kidnapper took his victim to a
construction site where he stepped in
wet cement leaving behind an identical
shoe print a short while later a teenage
girl named whitney bennett was attacked
with a tire iron during a break-in and
her assailant left behind the same print
at that point it became obvious that all
of these crimes as varied as they were
were all being committed by the same men
in may the night stalker resumed his
killing spree on the night of may 14
1985 he attacked bill and lillian doy in
their home in monterey park first he
shot bill doy in the face before
restraining his wife with thumb cuffs
and raping her afterwards he once again
proceeded to ransack the house looking
for valuables to steal lily and doy
recovered from her injuries her husband
was still clinging to life when the
nightstalker left their house but he
died in the hospital once more
detectives discovered the same unique
footprint at the crime scene this time
in the flabbert the shoe prince would be
found at a few more crime scenes but
eventually it would turn out to be a
dead end of course we now know that
ultimately it didn't matter because the
night stalker was caught without it but
at the time it was considered a major
step back when the police lost one of
their biggest leads this happened when
the mayor of san francisco dianne
feinstein accidentally revealed the clue
in a press conference unaware that it
was privileged information after that
the killer got rid of the sneakers and
they've never been recovered now okay
we'll get back to our story in just a
minute but first here's a word from
today's fantastic video sponsor fabulous
fabulous is the number one self-care
that helps you build better habits and
achieve your goals fabulous uses the
proven tenets of behavioral science to
help you build healthy habits one task
at a time so how does it work well let's
say you're working from home but you're
struggling to fit exercise and healthy
eating into a new routine or maybe
you're a writer who's having trouble
finding time throughout the day to put
pen to paper you see everybody's got
something they're trying to work on
right fabulous is going to help you
create new habits that really last by
giving you a friendly intuitive day
planner that'll help you create a long
lasting routine it's self-guided mode
helps you keep on track by breaking down
larger tasks into smaller bite-sized
goals or if you're looking for something
a little more active fabulous can offer
advice and guidance on everything from
professional development to mental
wellness pretty soon you're checking
things off your calendar like an
absolute ceo boss man it's like having
both a task manager and a coach right in
the palm of your hand so create yourself
a little schedule with the task list and
let fabulous keep you honest before you
know it fabulous has gotten you into a
good routine and you're well on your way
to achieving your personal goals so it's
time to start building your ideal daily
routine right now as a special deal for
you guys the first 100 people to click
in the link in the description below
we'll get a week for free plus 25 off a
fabulous premium membership so get over
there try it out and let's get back to
today's video
the next attack occurred a couple of
weeks after the doi family on may 29
1985 the night stalker drove to monrovia
where he broke into the house of two
elderly sisters named mabel bell and
florence lang both in their 80s this
time he used a hammer and an electrical
cord to assault the two women afterwards
looting their home and leaving them to
their fate they were discovered a couple
of days later by which point both
sisters were still alive although in
critical condition florence lang
recovered but mabel bell died in the
hospital what made this crime scene
immediately stand out from the others
was that the night stalker used lipstick
to draw pentagrams on the walls of the
house and on mabel bell's thigh this was
the first time that he indicated a
connection to satanism which would
become much more prevalent in the crimes
that followed and during his trial his
appetite for violence had not been sated
yet so the night stalker struck again
the very next day this time he picked
the house of a 42 year old carol kyle
who lived in burbank with her an 11 year
old son he handcuffed the boy and locked
him in the closet and then sexually
assaulted carol carl repeatedly warning
her not to look at him and that he would
shoot her if she did afterwards he
locked her in the closet as well and
looted the place before leaving without
killing anyone the nightstalker likely
claimed one victim in the month of june
32 year old patty elaine higgins who was
found in her home with numerous stab
wounds and a throat slashed although a
neighbor said she saw ramirez on the
night of higgins death ultimately he was
never tried for a murder so she is not
part of his convicted kill count which
stands at 13 even though ramirez himself
bragged in prison that he killed a lot
more than that we know for a fact of one
murder that had not been linked to him
until 2009 25 years after it actually
happened it occurred on april the 10th
1984 placing it before the night stalker
killing spree and even before the death
of ginny vingkow making it ramirez's
first known murder on that day ramirez
lured a nine-year-old girl named mei
lung into a department building her body
was later found hanging from a pipe and
dna evidence left at the crime scene
connected the crime to the night stalker
decades later as for patty higgins the
reason why the prosecution never went
after ramirez for her murder was because
his defense attorney successfully argued
that it was a weak case against their
client that would be unfairly tainted by
lumping it together with other cases
with much stronger evidence ultimately
the judge dismissed the charge entirely
in order to avoid having a separate
trial for it but there remains very
little doubt in anyone's mind that patty
higgins was a victim of the night
stalker
[Music]
july 1985 proved to be the busiest month
of the night stalker's criminal career
committing no less than six separate
attacks targeting nine people first came
the murder of 75 year old mary louise
cannon who was found dead in her home in
arcadia on july the 2nd her killer
attacked her while she slept first
bludgeoning her with a lamp and then
stabbing her with kitchen knife as
always the night stalker rummaged
through her home afterwards to steal
anything of value just three days later
ramirez attacked teenager whitney
bennett with the tire iron but she
survived the encounter even though she
needed hundreds of stitches on july the
7th the nightstalker committed two
attacks both in monterey park sophia
dickman was restrained and sexually
assaulted but ramirez did not try to
kill her joyce nelson however felt the
full brunt of his murderous wrath as the
night stalker bludgeoned and stomped her
to death leaving the familiar aviar
sneaker shoe print on the side of her
head july the 20th was another double
event for ramirez as he targeted two
households in different parts of los
angeles county one in glendale and the
other in sun valley first were maxson
and leela needing an elderly couple in
their late 60s the night stalker broke
into the home with a gun and a machete
after striking at both victims with the
machete he killed them both with shots
to the head then continued to mutilate
their bodies with the blade afterwards
he robbed their home and left leaving
behind his 22 caliber gun for some
unknown reason he already had another
firearm by this point but this move
allowed the police to positively connect
the murders with some of the previous
shootings after he killed the needings
that nightstalker drove to sun valley in
a stolen car and broke into the home of
the cavanaugh family the patriarch of
the family thirty-two-year-old chain
iron cavanaugh was targeted first he was
killed instantly with a shot to the head
while he slept his wife songkid was
beaten and raped and their
eight-year-old son was restrained while
ramirez plundered the home for valuables
august was almost as busy for ramirez he
started on the night of the sixth
breaking into the northridge home of
chris and virginia peterson he walked
into their master bedroom as they slept
and shot them both point-blank with a
25-caliber pistol virginia was hit in
the head and her husband in the neck but
miraculously they both survived their
injuries feeding off pure adrenaline
chris peterson even managed to get up
and charged the intruder who fired two
more shots and missed before fleeing the
crime scene obviously this attack did
not go as ramirez intended so he only
waited two days before striking again
this time in diamond bar california the
nightstalker broke into the home of
elias and sakina abbawaz killing the
husband right away before attacking the
wife ramirez threatened the lives of
sekina's two young sons in order to get
it to cooperate and afterwards came his
usual mo of sexual assault and robbery
his next attack occurred on august the
18th but it was unique because it took
place in san francisco as far as we know
this was the first time that the night
stalker left los angeles county for one
of his break-ins he targeted the home of
peter and barbara pan both were shot in
the head but barbara survived her
injuries even though he traveled to a
different county there was little doubt
in the investigator's mind that they
were dealing with the same killer he had
drawn pentagrams on the walls just like
the night stalker did and the bullets
came from the same 25 caliber gun as the
previous two attacks peter pan ended up
becoming the night stalker's last murder
victim ramirez committed one attack
after that this time in mission viejo
outside of la county on august 24th he
shot 30-year-old bill kahns three times
in the head before beating up and raping
his fiancee inez eriksen but khan's
pulled through and survived his injuries
these last two months had been a torrent
of violence and death but the tables
would soon be turned on the night
stalker as ramirez would receive a lot
more notoriety than he bargained for
throughout his entire killing spree the
nightstalker made little effort to
conceal his tracks leaving behind
evidence and plenty of witnesses who
could identify as it would be later
revealed at his trial he thought he was
being protected by the devil when in
reality it was the pure random nature
and the large coverage area of his
attacks which kept the police one step
behind him the one thing that the killer
did take the time to do was not leave
any fingerprints the police have long
considered that finding a print would be
the key to identifying their man and
toward the end of august they got their
wish it all started on august 24th the
same night as the attack on bill khan's
and inez ericsson the nightstalker tried
to assault another family in mission
viejo the romero's but he was spotted
and ran away as he was leaving
thirteen-year-old james ramirez saw the
make model and part of the license plate
of the stolen car that miros was driving
an orange toyota station wagon and he
told the police working with this new
lead investigators found the stolen
vehicle and inside they found the big
break in their case a fingerprint this
was still the 1980s so there was no
automated database things went a little
slower but a week later police finally
had a name richard ramirez his prince
were on a file from a car theft charge
back in 1984 and by the end of the month
his face was plastered all over the city
ramirez had actually been out of town
for a few days trying to visit his
brother in arizona when he returned to
los angeles on august 31st he had no
idea that he was the most wanted man in
the city he first realized when he saw
his face on the front page of a
newspaper inside a liquor store and was
recognized by some bystanders who began
shouting to the police he made a run for
it and he tried to carjack a woman named
angie delatore she screamed for help and
soon enough the entire neighborhood
descended upon ramirez hitting him with
boots fists metal poles barbecue tongs
and whatever else they could grab they
were not afraid of him anymore in that
moment he wasn't a bogeyman who struck
at you while you were most vulnerable he
was just another violent junkie by the
time the police arrived they had to save
the killer from his victims not the
other way around
so who was the night stalker he was born
ricardo lever munoz ramirez on february
29 1960 in el paso texas the youngest of
five children of julian and mercedes
ramirez his father smacked him around
when he was a kid but it was his older
cousin who had the most influence on him
growing up to the outside world miguel
mike ramirez was a green beret and
respected vietnam veteran richard
however knew the true sadistic side of
his cousin who had told him stories of
how he raped tortured and murdered
vietnamese women and even showed him
polaroids of himself in action then when
he was 13 years old richard ramirez
witnessed his cousin murder his wife
during an argument by shooting her in
the face after that event his behavior
and demeanor changed he used a lot of
drugs started committing petty crimes
and also developed an interest in
satanism all the building blocks for
making the night stalker have been laid
down his trial as a media circus quickly
turning into the most expensive trial in
the history of los angeles county until
the o.j simpson case a few years later
ramirez was enjoying his newfound fame
oftentimes showing pentagrams to the
camera or shouting hail satan during the
hearings his lawyers tried every trick
in the book to get the proceedings
delayed or moved and although they
managed to stretch the trial over
multiple years the result was still
definitive richard ramirez was found
guilty of over 40 charges including 13
counts of murder and he was sentenced to
death he spent the next 24 years of his
life on death row at san quentin state
prison he even got married in 1996 to
one of his groupies who fell in love
with him during the trial who described
ramirez as being kind funny charming and
a really great person she eventually
divorced him in 2009 when the police
linked him to the murder of
eight-year-old bei lung but he got
engaged to another woman soon after
ramirez died on june 7 2013 due to
complications from b cell lymphoma
leaving behind a legacy of terror unlike
any other in the history of los angeles
he never expressed any remorse for his
actions and when he received the death
penalty he simply said big deal death
always comes with a territory
see you in disneyland
so i'm not going to ask whether you
enjoyed today's video but i do hope you
found it interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe
thank you for watching
[Music]
you